[Applause]
well-well-well Wendy Williams you have a
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame I saw
the tears if I don't laugh or cry so
we'll keep it light and laughter II okay
okay okay okay okay okay what does this
mean to you everything I mean it's it's
a combination of over 30 years of being
a personality and you know it's not easy
being on TV for 10 years by yourself
live and this has been a really hectic
year for me but also hectic career you
know triumph over adversity stick to it
Wendy you'll show them you'll show them
and now it's my pleasure to show you you
said it's been quite a year how does
this punctuate that year and as you look
back on that year what jumps out to you
that makes you think wow I overcame that
and I did it my son is here with me
simple you know young Kevin I and my
nephew we flew out here he's only known
me he's only 19 so he's only known me
for mom with the microphone you know and
then and then mom in the headlines and
then and and mom saying how to order
stuff and or but he knows the good stuff
and he's here so this star means
everything because now he's got
something to look at and say my mom did
it
she's alright real quick will you come
back out here after all this hubbub is
done and will you come back out here and
walk around your star later at night
just you know in a hat or something
getting away well I'm going to the club
tonight so are you going to the club
with Wendy are you going to worry about
that don't you worry about that I'm
going to the club tonight and after the
club I definitely intend on having my
moment with my own star with eyeballs in
the back of my head okay
okay I might not be from here but I read
stuff okay
congratulations winner
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]